PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So today I'd like
to look at a problem
on manipulating Fourier series.
Specifically, we're
asked to find the Fourier
series of cosine 2t minus pi/4.
And then the second problem
is given a square wave
function, which takes on
the value of minus 1 and 1,
and it's 2pi periodic.
We're also told that the square
wave function has the Fourier
series 4/pi, 1/n sine n*t.
And the question is to find the
Fourier series of three related
functions.
So the first function takes
on the value of 0 and 4
on the intervals minus
pi to 0 and 0 to pi.
Note that this function
is also 2pi periodic.
The second problem it is
to find the Fourier series
of a function which is
minus 1 from minus 1 to 0,
and 1 from 0 to 1.
So this is the
square wave function,
but now has period two.
And then lastly
we're asked to find
the Fourier series of a function
f of t, which is absolute t.
And it's defined as
absolute t on the interval
from minus pi to pi.
However this function
f is going to be
extended on the entire
domain with period 2pi.
So I'll let you think
about this problem
and I'll be back in a moment.
Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So let's take a look
at the first problem,
finding the Fourier series
of cosine 2t minus pi/4.
So in this class when we say
find the Fourier series, what
we're really looking for are
coefficients a_0, a_n and b_n,
such that, for example, we
can write our function out
as a sum of sine and cosines
with these values a_n and b_n.
Now, what we could do is we
could take this function,
plug it into the
integral formulas
and compute, using integrals,
the value a_0, a_n, and b_n.
However, there's
a bit of a trick.
And that's to realize that this
function, cosine 2t minus pi/4,
is really just a
sinusoidal function
with a single frequency.
And it's currently in
an amplitude-phase form.
And we can always convert
an amplitude-phase form
of a sinusoidal function into
some amplitude times a sine
and some amplitude times a
cosine and add the two up.
So specifically,
this can be done
by recalling the
cosine identity,
cosine A minus B is
cosine A times cosine
B plus sine of A sine of B.
And if we identify A
with 2t and B with pi/4,
we obtain that f of
t is cosine 2t cosine
pi/4 plus sine 2t sine of pi/4.
And now sine pi/4 and cosine
pi/4 are both 1 over root 2.
So f of t becomes 1
over root 2 cosine 2t
plus 1 over root 2 sine 2t.
And that's it.
So when we take a look at
this expression for f of t,
we see that this is actually
in exactly the same form
that we were seeking in the
beginning, the Fourier series
representation for f.
So this is the end
of the problem.
We don't have to actually
compute any integrals.
So now let's take
a look at part two.
So for part two, we're asked
to find the Fourier series
of several different functions.
And I'll just take
a look at part one.
So in this case, f of t
takes on the value of 0
from minus pi to zero, and
the value of 4 from 0 to pi.
And if I were to quickly
sketch this function,
it would look like a square
wave, 0, pi, minus pi.
This is f of t.
And we see that it's actually
related-- I can draw in dashes
just to be clear-- what
the original square wave
function might look like.
So this is square wave of t.
We see that if we were to
take the square wave function
and shift it up, the square
wave takes on values of plus 1
and minus 1.
But if we take the
square wave function
and shift it up 1 unit,
and then rescale it,
we'll then get the function
we're looking for, f of t.
So specifically, we can
write f of t in terms
of the square wave as well.
We have to shift the
square wave function up 1,
and then we have to amplify
it by a factor of 2.
So then when we seek the Fourier
series for f, all we have to do
is substitute the Fourier series
for the square wave function
in.
So let's do this.
So we have 1 plus 4/pi.
So I'm writing here this Fourier
series for the square wave
function, n odd, 1/n sine n*t.
So by manipulating the Fourier
series for the square wave
function, we can arrive at
a Fourier series for f of t,
n odd, 1/n sine n*t.
So this is the first function.
The second function f
of t-- I'll just rewrite
it again-- f of t takes
on the value of negative 1
from negative 1 to 0, and
takes on the value of plus 1
from 0 to 1.
So it's somewhat useful to
draw, just to quickly sketch,
this function.
And I'll draw in my axes here.
So this is f of t.
This is t.
And it transitions.
It makes its jumps
at the integers.
So for example, it jumps
from plus 1 to minus 1 at 1,
and from plus 1 to minus
1 at minus 1 as well.
And if I were to just quickly
sketch the square wave function
underneath of it, the
square wave function
makes its transitions
at minus pi and pi.
So this is the
square wave function.
This is t.
So we see that we can take
the square wave function
and squeeze it to obtain
this function f of t.
And the question
now is, what factor
do we have to squeeze the square
wave function by to get f of t?
Well, usually what
I like to do is
take one characteristic
point in the sketch
for in this case the
square wave function.
So a nice
characteristic point is
when the square wave
function has a 0,
so when it goes
through the origin,
and compare it to the same
point on this function f of t.
So we see that the
point pi has to get
stretched to the point 1.
So we basically need to take
the time axis in the square wave
function and squeeze
it by a factor of pi.
So what this means
is that f of t
is going to be the square wave.
And when we do what
mathematicians sometimes
called a dilatation, a
stretch or a squeeze.
If we're squeezing
by some factor,
that factor always appears in
the argument of the function
we're squeezing.
If it's a stretch, then it would
be t over the stretch factor.
And we can quickly check
here that if t equals 1,
so as t goes from 0
to 1, so when t is 1,
the square wave function
is being evaluated at pi.
And I'll now write out
the Fourier series.
So this is going to be 4/pi, sum
of n odd, 1/n sine of n*pi*t.
And there's another
quick check we can do.
And that's this
function f we were told
is periodic with period 2.
And if we just take a look
at this function here,
the Fourier series
representation of it,
we see that each sine n*pi*t is
in fact periodic with period 2.
So that's just another quick,
back of the envelope check
that we've done our
calculation correctly.
So this concludes part two.
And then lastly than
for part three, f of t
is the absolute value of
t from minus pi to pi.
And it's extended
beyond minus pi to pi
to make it 2pi periodic.
And at first it might look
like this function f of t
is not related to the
square wave function.
But if we look at it a
little more carefully,
and analyze the
derivative of f of t,
we see that this function
takes on the value plus 1
on the interval of 0 to pi and
takes on the value of minus 1
on the interval
of minus pi to 0.
And this is exactly
the square wave.
So what we can do
is we can write
f of t-- it's going to be an
integral of the square wave
function.
So specifically, we have
the integral of square wave,
which is going to be the
integral of 4/pi 1/n sine n*t,
summation n odd.
And I'm going to leave this
as an indefinite integral.
So when we integrate, we have
a constant of integration
c plus 4/pi sum of 1
over now n squared.
And we have negative cosine n*t.
And this is n odd again.
And now we have one
last question to answer.
What is the constant
of integration?
Well, notice how the
constant of integration
can be identified with the
a_0 term of a Fourier series.
So if we want the
constant of integration,
we can just
calculate it directly
by the integral formula for
the a_0 of this function.
So what this means is c
is going to be 1/(2pi)--
essentially it's just the
average of the function--
but it's pi to pi, the absolute
value of t, which is 1/pi,
pi squared over 2.
So we get pi/2.
So just to quickly
recap, in this problem
we were given several
functions which were related
to the square wave function.
And we started off
knowing what the Fourier
series for the square
wave function was.
And by manipulating or
rewriting these functions
in terms of the
square wave function,
we were able to compute
their Fourier series.
And we were able to
do this essentially
without having to
evaluate any integrals.
OK.
So I hope you
enjoyed this problem,
and I'll see you next time.